hello welcome to this video playing
Prince panic here this is really Hendrix
I always have black and I'm lost the
last Italian game and I feel I shouldn't
I should somehow play it better than I
did in that game let's see let's see i
played this Knight a5 business I really
wonder he can go here am I doing this
wrong somehow is that not good at all I
mean he's playing this very quickly it
said he plays it like what I'm doing is
bad maybe it is we had the same thing
just later today and later today earlier
today it wasn't all that great but now
i'm basically stuck with it ok some
probably yes an improvement anyway i
mean even before we get to the position
that was worse for me ok let's do
something else even though I'm not not
particularly happy with this him I had
the Italian game is really this is
really bothering me i'm currently not
working on it i mean whenever i try him
I'm so utterly bored and I do i do
something and working i'm looking one
other content at the moment there is a
bit more interesting to look at so I'm
not fixing this this this problem at the
moment and came
you know anyway take it take it 1b form
kind of has to take almost I mean that
otherwise I'll grab a four wow really
why can I not take a four-set problem
should I mean understand that he gets
the pawn back but I would have thought
that this is kind of helpful for me that
I'm gonna pawn down well anyway take
first think later and and in fact if he
takes with the Queen there is d5 so he
act he should lose some material he
actually if he takes with the Queen 35
hmm okay
interesting I'm also threatening Knight
c3 year winning the exchange basically
attacking the Queen threatening 92 so
you probably got himself into some
trouble here yeah 93 is this wins an
exchange more or less clap okay so take
this and now let's see how this works
he's got pretty active pieces so it's
not like um completely trivial win with
the next changeup and what what's going
on here here's got potentially be six
Luke c7 this is a bad Bishop there okay
let's see for I can play in Bishop takes
f 3 i'm returning the exchange then I
don't mind this should be I I don't
think he I don't think you should have
done that Mindy success is this kind of
weakish barbecues go ten it's probably
just just go on but I'm getting active
them let's see how to do this
yeah I've 7s under some pressure if I go
there I would love to play the rukon the
second ring but 96's immediately maybe I
should still do that actually let's not
be 6 as well ok ok ok so what to do
maybe this again I don't want to
exchange loss and he doesn't even
consider them kind of can almost suspect
that so I wanted to activate the roku
and now what's the deal g 697 well there
should've moved this
okay I don't want hi Barney do want to
trade here necessarily but not known at
age six is not coming no negative 6 is
not coming what is he threatening here
Bishop King Queen have six maybe twin f6
is a threat yeah this is a threat at the
anti he takes b7 this is this oh my god
and now Queen f6 that I'm losing or what
don't don't give me that yeah I think
I'm losing here come on this is crazy
this is crazy stuff what a sick game
what a sick game and its of course on my
own for ya I completely outplayed myself
you have to bring an exchange of ah come
on black resigns what an idiot I am
already you just gave me that game on a
silver plate and very easy stuff ha
given that knowing this is crazy really
crazy ha and that I'm not winning this
now is just completely embarrassing so
here this and now whatever I am probably
just like g6 and queen d 8 come on again
can switch that on yeah
in da to activate the Queen well as I
still don't like this I should I
shouldn't even get there really also
here maybe just defend these six or
something maybe I should just defend the
pawn for the moment and and wait until
I'm properly sorted 27 office engines
move but I mean there's nothing wrong
with i don't know like this just defend
this for the moment and kind of sort my
position I love it Queen next and so on
it's just an exchange down I mean those
are active but but don't tell me this is
any good young stupid yeah if it if we
get if he gives if he takes the exchange
this is a very one-sided position which
is easy to play yeah I can mumbai King a
safer here than his King I have ideas to
enter this is not much as you as you see
with the engine but this very simple to
play this is why I didn't mind him to
take my exchange and he didn't because
this poses more problems so all that was
was kind of cleared and ta a queen d8
still wins I mean yeah I have to cover
have six I mean I just the Girl Scout if
I didn't want to do that yeah because
this eve doesn't work I kept this I can
play like an idiot here really and then
I can just play the ending and when I
mean jack this is winning if I'm not
losing the be born and someday sale you
know nothing's going to work here and
this is one of those days so basically
everything went so not just not this
okay great hey okay
so maybe the next game is bad of it it's
always a question if you if you know we
have a bad day do you end the session
quit playing on do you do one or two
more games because you have there's
actually one of the few days where you
have time to record stuff and then you
play like a [ __ ] anyway I think I want
to play one or two more thanks for
watching